let me ask you about some particles
okay first the absurd question almost
like uh
a question that like plato would ask
what is the smallest thing in the
universe
as far as we know the the
fundamental particles out of which we
build
our most successful description of
nature
are points they have zero they have
don't have any
internal structure that's they uh
so that's as small as can be
to uh so what does that mean
operationally that means
if you that they obey equations that
describe
entities that are singular
concentrations of energy momentum
angular momentum the things that
particles have but localized at
individual points now that
mathematical structure is
only revealed partially in the world
because to
to process the wave function in a way
that that
that accesses information about the
precise position of things you have to
apply a lot of energy
and that's not you know we that's an
idealization that you can apply infinite
amount of energy to determine a
precise position but at the mathematical
level
uh we build the world out of particles
that are points
so do they actually exist and what are
we talking about so like oh they exist
so let me ask sort of uh do quarks exist
yes two electrons exist
yes two photons exist yes but what does
it mean for them to exist
okay so well the hard answer to that the
precise answer
is that uh we construct the world
out of equations that contain entities
that
are reproducible that exist in
vast numbers throughout the universe
that have definite properties of
mass spin and a few others
that we call electrons
and the what what an electron is is
defined by the equations that it
satisfies
theoretically and we find that there are
many many
exemplars of that of
that entity in the physical world so
in elect in the case of electrons we can
you know
isolate them and study them in
individual ones in great detail and we
can check that they
all actually are identical
uh and that's why chemistry works and
yes so
so so that in that case uh it's very
tangible
similarly with photons you can study
them individually
they're the units of light uh
and uh nowadays it's very practical to
study individual photons and determine
their
uh their spin and their other basic
properties and
uh uh and check out the equations in
great detail for quarks
and gluons which are the other two main
ingredients of our model of matter
that's so successful it's a little more
complicated because the quarks and
gluons
that appear in our equations don't
appear
directly as particles you can isolate
and study individually they always occur
within uh bound to what are called bound
states or structures like protons or
a proton roughly speaking is composed of
three quarks and a lot of gluons but
we can detect them in a remarkably
direct way actually nowadays
whereas at relatively low energies
uh the behavior of quarks is complicated
at high energies they can prop they can
propagate through space relatively
freely
for a while and we can see their tracks
so ultimately they get recaptured into
protons and other
mesons and funny things but for a short
time
they propagate freely and while that
happens we can
take snapshots and see see their
manifestations
uh this is the actually this kind of
thing is exactly what i got the nobel
prize for
predicting that this would work and
similarly for gluons although you you
can't
uh you can't isolate them as individual
particles and study them in the same way
we study electrons say
uh you can
use them to as use them theoretically as
entities out of which you
build tangible description tangible
things that we actually do observe uh
but also
you can uh at accelerators at high
energy you can liberate them for brief
periods of time and study
how they that that and and get
convincing evidence that they
they they leave tracks and and you can
get convincing evidence that they were
there and
have the properties that we wanted them
to have
you